نور اغا جندي سابق فقد رجليه جراء انفجار
قنبله وسط العاصمه كابول قبل اربع سنوات
ومنذ ذلك الوقت يستخدم رجلين صناعيتين
يقول انه لغداءه الصنع واجه مشاكل كثيره
خلال هذه المده طبلق الان هنا للحصول على
رجلين صناعيتين جديدتين وقد صنعوهما لي
امل ان تكون مرحه
محمد خان هو الثاني الذي فقد رجليه منذ
اربعين عاما يقول ان العيش صعب بالنسبه
لذوي الاعاقات وان استخدام هذه الارجل
المصنوعه ليس مريحا على الاطلاق
لاول مره ومنذ اربعه اشهر حصلت على رجلين
صناعيتين مريحتين الى حد ما حيث استطيع
المشي فيهما ساعه او ساعتين واستطيع ان
اقوم فيها بحياتي على الرغم من وجود وزاره
مستقله تعنى بورثه اهالي الضحايا والارامل
والمصابين فانه لا توجد احصائيات دقيقه
لعدد من فقدوا اطرافهم في افغانستان في
وقت تفيد مسوحات اجرتها جهات مستقله بان
عددهم ثلاثه ملايين نحن الى هذا الوقت
سجلنا خمسه وخمسين الف ومئه الف شخص معاق
وتستمر عمليه التسجيل
بحسب المعاقين فان الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه
يحتاجون بشكل خاص الى الدعم المالي
والنفسي مضيفين انه يجب على منظمات
الاغاثه الدوليه
مساعدتهم دون انقطاع
وفقا لبحث اجرتهم مؤسسه اسيا يوجد في
افغانستان اكبر عدد من الاشخاص ذوي
الاعاقه في العالم يتشاركون بنوع واحد من
الاعاقه نتيجه لاكثر من اربعه عقود من
الحروب والالغام الارضيه والذخائر غير
المنفجره التي خلفتها الحرب عبد الانادر
العربيه كابول